mes amis alors écoutez je suis
particulièrement heureux de vivre avez
vous une aventure folle qui est un petit
peu original est extraordinaire nous
avons aujourd'hui la chance d'accueillir
d'éminents cadre de la maison jean le
travail ont bien sûr pour la musique
d'abord pour le public ensuite mais pour
tous les publics qu'ils soient enfants
qu'ils soient jeunes qu'ils soient
mélomanes qu'ils soient néophytes
ouais c'est assez rare en 30 ans
on n'a pas eu souvent parfois on a
souvent des enfants viennent évidemment
des gamins avec des classes dans toutes
nos actions pédagogiques
mais
des adultes assez peu finalement
pas de culpabilisation surtout de ne pas
être dans vos joueurs vous le retour au
bureau aujourd'hui ça je me disais les
peaux via la commission dans très
consciencieux ils doivent sûrement
culpabiliser voulait jouer mettre là je
vais être un peu des autres un peu au
large monsieur je maintiens est
peut-être là non je me mets la wii le
chef d'orchestre il voilà il lève la
baguette il la baisse et dans le fait de
ce geste là il indique le tempo comme
vous pourriez indiqué à votre équipe à
votre groupe
le tempo le projet que vous voulez
développe
sans accent qu'on n'entende pas le
changement archet surtout changer l'un
après l'autre
et on coupe la
là vous vibrer dans le trash and an
faut voir ses idées bien claires dans la
tête il faut que chaque musicien sentent
que vous lui permettez de jouer le mieux
possible sa partition ce qui est je
crois la première vertu d'un chef qui
est de fond servir le compositeur et
servir les musiciens
à
et de savoir
c
à
et
oui
très joli
lycée bien tous ensemble à l'extrémité
du temps
paul tanner ou au dessus du milieu voilà
ici c'est le chemin et ça c'est la main
du coeur lama d'expression la main de la
sna couleurs de la sonorité de la
sensibilité donc vous dirigez le rythme
ne vend plus
prépare au bout de trois minutes en face
d'un orchestre peut pas leur raconter
d'histoires ils savent y avait avait
autrefois le père de richard strauss de
charges cross le compositeur son père
était un corniste étaient dans leurs
caisses de munich et il était
extraordinairement et esthète de l'arc
disait quand on voit monter le chef au
public
on sait qui de lui ou de nous sera le
attention les trombones vous êtes en
retard sur moi sur les troisièmes temps
c'est bien
ces jeunes ne viennent là que parce
qu'ils ont envie de jouer
tu parles des jeunes musiciens de
l'orchestré des jeunes ils ont un idéal
je pense qu'ils sont les ferments
d'espérance de notre futur musicale j'en
ai beaucoup dans leurs caisses qui sont
passés par leur caisse français des
jeunes parce que un ensemble artistique
ça passe avant tout par une mentalité
vous avez des gens hyper sensible du
ceux d'histoire qu'est ce qui va nous
raconter suis là et donc il faut faire
passer la conception donc je pense qu'il
ya des proximités entre vos métiers et
les nôtres c'est à dire essayer
collectivement d'avoir une vision et
puis à l'intérieur de du groupe que
chacun soit bien la semblance oui j'ai
fait une réputation ce matin de trois
heures sans pause avec tout mon poids
tiers 68 60 cordes seul pendant une
heure et demie
on
et ensuite 70 autres musiciens de
l'harmonie
là des gens qui vous pardonne rien c'est
un orchestre c'est très exigeant
donc vous devez arriver préparer c'est à
dire que vous devez savoir exactement où
ça n'ira pas où il faut travailler à
détail où ce travail est une couleur où
il faut travailler un rythme
ensuite vous vous cet après midi nous
avons fait au fond comme une première
lecture tout le monde oui mais tout est
déjà en place comme vous avez pu le
constater c'est c'était acceptable
c'était audible
donnez moi une deux trois quatre avants
16 s'il vous plaît pour l'enchaînement
pas non maintenant madame quatre avants
16 denis 96 et pour qu'on sait bien
ensemble sur l'accord s'il vous plaît eh
oui
tempo gym individuellement ils ont des
marges de manoeuvre ils ont un peu oui
non non un peu oui les solistes parfois
c'est là où justement vous pouvez donner
la liberté laissée jouer à condition que
ce soit en relation avec ce que vous
croyez être la justesse de la conception
je les considère absolument comme des
collègues et le rapport comme vous le
voyez sont très très s'en sont tout à
fait il ya une empathie mais voilà
oui pas trop trop détendu lacrost en
plus d'en diminuer n'doh n'est ce pas on
refait 16 si vous voulez sébastien et
pas d'embellie
c'est ça un tout petit peu un tout petit
peu loustics si j'ose dire
tabac drogue voyez ce que je veux dire
daniel comme ça on le fera avec
on fera avec votre voiture vous avez des
très grands solistes dans les orchestres
ici de chez moi j'ai des gens dont je
suis particulièrement fier mais si vous
occuper que de lui vous raté les autres
un réseau ne sont pas contents mais
abandonner s'il a une grande mélodie
vous contrôlez les autres pour pâques et
lui coupe la parole pour pâques
halloween les tous et vous pouvez le
laisser jouer
la hollande en dire
dire marché 1
non
c'est bien daniel robin
là
chef d'orchestre c'est un état c'est une
philosophie
parfois un destin beaucoup de
psychologie pour faire passer une idée
il faut parfois ses excuses et de
demander pardon parce que ils sont
susceptibles ils sont a priori contre le
chef surtout s'il a fait une ou deux
maladresses alors là faut remonter le
courant après c'est très difficile pour
respecter d'abord la musique s'y sentent
que vous faites exactement ce qui est
sûr la musique vous lui pardonne on s'y
sent que vous faites autre chose il
faudra justifier ce que vous aurez
toujours quelqu'un que vous dire
pourquoi on fait ça là le marquer ça ben
je le sens comme ça que oui m'enfin tout
de même pourquoi dites moi pourquoi ils
sont légitimes
on est sous contrôle permanent même si
on donne l'illusion dirigé toulouse
oui vous allez de gentils vous allez
allonger un peu la première croche
la première croche qui se trouve une
deux trois quatre cinq la sixième de 24
seuls deux sens l'a10 dans dida avec un
tout petit peu plus de convivialité
parce que la flexibilité de ce mouvement
est quand même un tout petit peu tout
petit peu délicate à maîtriser
il a dit c'est tout ça est un peu rubato
unis qu'il faut savoir
fava la modestie de se dire je dois être
digne de les diriger le problème
d'ailleurs ça passe par le respect de la
musique il le respect des musiciens
alors tu connais l'histoire jeu plus à
jouer déjà pu la jouer déjà ça
l'enterrement du chasseur par les
animaux de la forêt une mélodie qui ne
doit pas de label contrebasse je vous
sent vibrer et qui est beau c'est donc
l'envers si tu veux pas de ce que vous
faites merveilleusement habitudes se
compteraient quelque chose de voir où
joue sa patte au si j'ose dire quoi je
fais la timbale oui
as-tu fait la timbale très bien fait la
timbale alors la pause début 75% pas
trop lent pendant que derrière moi ça
mal en retard un peu 3 et 4 et pom pom
pom pom pom pom boy
respire une petite respiration à la fin
du quatrième temps voilà
respire
respire voilà
là
aspyr ça va être formidable mathieu
bravo oui le chasseur est très à poil
dans son cercueil
chaque fois il ya respiration après
j'attends le prochain une toute petite
voix soit entendue pas 3 et 4 et
ne vibre pas à son blanc voilà les
centres et chendo en poussant
une auto
deux noms non
c'est très bien mathieu sait très bien
plus ça sera l'envers de ta sensibilité
de la beauté tension déjà bretelle du de
tous mieux ce sera pour ces c c c et
huit mesures
je crois que la mission d'un leader quel
qu'il soit c'est d'essayer de réduire la
distance est de favoriser la
compréhension comme un chef d'entreprise
je crois si se met à parler un langage
abscons
quand il n'y a pas d'histoire il y avait
une belle histoire et on vous voyait
effectivement témoigner toute cette
émotion mais quand il n'y a pas
d'histoire savez en général aux
musiciens je leur raconte jamais une
histoire l'émission pas besoin d'un
cours ni l'histoire ni musicologie ils
sont là pour jouer ce qu'ils ont devant
eux avant ou après ils peuvent poser des
questions on peut discuter
alors parfois vous donner une image une
métaphore ça peut éclairer un passage
d'interprétation ça c'est important
mais faut pas trop trop faut pas trop
exagérer dans la métaphore s'il ya un
jour un chef d'orchestre qui dit hao
bois qui ne comprenaient pas ce qu'ils
voulaient à monsieur monsieur s'il vous
plaît je voudrais ici
faites moi une couleur mauve lommois
l'on regarde lui c'est oui m écouter ces
fortes et où ses pianos voilà c'est vrai
il faut être très très très pragmatique
très précis et très con si les musiciens
ont horreur de l'imprécision
oui égard des gardes et garder la
pression sur la dernière crush on you
did team comme vraiment quelque chose de
très très tendre on est trois fois trop
fort mes amis encore une fois s'il vous
plaît votre votre départ pour
je
ben ali
le pompage
le pas
ap ap jamie vos amis ça nous a mis
écouté que j'ai moi vous partez mais
avec la cie est pas bon il ya encore une
petite fois oui un soufflet voulait pas
soufflé annonce est faite le oui s'il
vous plaît c'est pas moi qui vous ai
demandé
oui c
non
ali toute la mittel europa qu'on aime
pour ceux qui l'aiment évidemment mais
moi je lève je me refais encore une fois
la mélopée s'il vous plaît aussi c'est
avec la levée est peu d'art chef de
marché
tout est dit
on a quand même une grande contrainte
c'est la musique c'est le texte le texte
il est très clairement il a dit
clairement ce que c'est qu'une double
croche un trio laid une blanche une
noire un tempo
tous
et
toujours s'interroger pour savoir si on
est bien certain que on serre la
partition est jamais dire je le fais
comme ça parce que je le sens et parfois
osées c'est à dire ah je vais essayer de
faire ça
c'est tout le mystère et l'irrationalité
tout de même au delà de l'analyse qui
permet la liberté et qui fait le talent
de l'interprète pas de crescendo au
basson du tout seulement la clarinette
merci
m
abhorré
hamon
je
oui parce que si moi je le regarde
l'organisation agricole cède donc la
gestuelle vous la voyez là c'est enfin
là où fut ma part je crois quand même
bouger les lignes qu'il ya comme
partition tout cas tout le monde at on
annoncé par action arrivé chez pas s'il
n'a répondu qu'à elle et tous mes notes
on me le dire s'il est revenu la famille
désire généralement savoir ce qu'il a
entendu si la campagne zéro tu as
tradition des jeux de langage et c'est
ok puis en mes qualités pour un chinois
tels que ceux que vous aimez le plus
maintenant qu'à long terme
moi j'ai un chef ou petraeus impôts oui
mais c'est ça pour préparer sa peau mais
ils ont besoin des femmes aiment bien
les chefs vous passiez pas
à
neutre
hé hé
un peu
fait cela
e
les amish petites choses petites choses
avant de vous et battre plus d'accent là
où ils sont placés à oui ça il faut que
vous le regardez un tout petit peu plus
précisément ce que je vais pas passer
évidemment trop de temps là-dessus ça
c'est une personnel mais un top 7 1 mars
dans le poignarde
donnez moi les premiers violons ce qu'il
vous plaît aux la mesure 41 une de la
troisième
excusez-moi de vous interrompre
troisième de 41 les premiers violons
merci de 80 ouais sûrement 80,6
évident
voilà type en p1 parme plus marcato
comme ça encore une fois savant 6-1 et
et
et f
arrête ils sont arrêtés sont arrêtés
l'archet donc ces jeunes dont je vous
disais que j'étais directeur musique on
leur donne la joie de l' orchestre
alors que quelquefois on a enseigné la
version de l' orchestre
alors qu'est ce c'est merveilleux
d'apporter sa pierre à l'édifice - une
de mes plus grandes émotions c'est la
première fois que j'ai fait de l'
orchestre
c'était la neuvième symphonie de
beethoven ou j'ai attendu 280 mesures
avant de donner pour un coût de triangle
et j'avais l'impression tout d'un coup
je participais à l'édifice collectif il
faut d'abord développer le plaisir
donc si cette joie et développer chez
les plus jeunes à ces sauver 5 6 et
ces partis da pimp à mettez un point sur
la double croche tous un pin penser plus
dramatique on est ce que je veux dire
quand une fois et un vont me tuer
5 6 1 et et aaa
voilà voilà la même chose - saic
maintenant parce que là c'est toi moi
comme ça voilà dans on refait cette
finale là ça va être merveilleux
donnez-moi le 10 62 19
le désir qui est éveillé de jouer passe
par la maîtrise que la maîtrise alors à
ce moment là c'est la discipline et la
rigueur on recommence dix fois jusqu'à
ce que ce soit bien mais à ce moment là
la discipline et la rigueur de vienne
volupté pour l'accomplissement du
plaisir
oui
ça donne la chair de poule moi même j'ai
la chair de boer
parce que sans ça on sera tous ensemble
sourire 2
ja de pierrot lunaire
tout notre coeur d'un jour là
jérôme bosch
le plus de charme en fait
hu
macha qui trempe ses pattes dans du lait
fois c'est bien reposé vous